[Music]
hello there you're watching the press
preview a first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive in the next
half hour we'll see what's making the
headlines with the editor of look the
local sheffield paper the star nancy
fielder and the white hall financial
times editor sebastian payne there they
are thank you so much for joining us um
let's see what's on some of those front
pages first the telegraph leads with a
fatal explosion at liverpool women's
hospital which killed one person and
injured another the daily mail also
focuses on that car explosion with three
men arrested by counter-terror police
following the incident
and the times reports that armed
officers and negotiators were sent to a
property in east liverpool
health fears for the queen is the
headline on the front of the metro after
she was forced to cancel her remembrance
sunday appearance just hours before the
senate half service
the guardian leads on cop 26 president
alok sharma's warning to india and china
that they will have to explain
themselves to poor nations after forcing
the watering down of the climate deal
meanwhile the financial times reports on
business groups joining climate
activists in expressing frustration at
the cop 26 agreement
and the star claims britain faces an
icelandic barrage of cold weather oh
that's great within days going with the
headline snow way out
and as i said we're joined tonight by
nancy and sebastian hello to you both
thanks for joining us let's kick off
shall we with cop and the guardian page
one nancy what do you think of this
agreement
well everybody seems pretty much in
agreement that the agreement isn't quite
what we've hoped for i mean it is a
massive step forward and it's great that
we have got some sort of international
agreement but for it to sort of falter
at the very very last minute um seems
disappointing doesn't it and it's hard
to keep hold of so many positives and
there are so many positives because
we're in the middle of a massive crisis
this was very much hailed as sort of
last chance saloon and yet there we go
in the very last hour the negotiations
changed so i think like everybody
kind of pleased that some things
happened but actually it's not enough is
it and we all know in our house that
this
it's not enough now
well not if you are listening to alex
sharma and boris johnson this evening or
this afternoon the ft sebastian your
paper um they're looking at businesses
joining with activists and saying
exactly that but what did you make of
boris johnson saying that actually
there doesn't seem to be a huge
difference between phasing down and
phasing out that language
well it's very different to what alok
sharma the president of cop was saying
because there was some very stark images
of him in tears at the situation i think
that was that last minute intervention
by india china and other countries to
water down that land so i think he might
have something to say about that because
obviously there is a key difference but
one of the big things to come off the
back of cop is a question about how you
implement all this and how you hold the
countries to these pledges because
obviously you've got that declaration
signed by over 200 countries and that
cop 27 and the next meeting of this
summit they will have to look at that
and they will have to examine whether
you know those pledges are being
implemented i think obviously boris
johnson in his usual way was trying to
put a nice positive spin on this and say
that in fact you know and we have done
something good and i think we shouldn't
undermine what has been done here it is
pretty impressive and i think getting
coal into that agreement was quite quite
crucial but
there are still those big questions
about developing nations and i think
really the question of the next 12
months is going to be turning some of
those pledges into reality and then
seeing when we come back to this where
the technology and economics have moved
on to keep that 1.5 dream alive and i
think it was both um alex sharma and
boris johnson who said at the press
conference today it was still possible i
think others i think ed miliband the
labour party said it's on life support
so this is an awful lot of work to be
done so you can understand why people
are pleased but also why many are
disappointed
quite an extensive write-up inside the
daily mail on cop26 and specifically
looking at that conference this
afternoon nancy what do you think about
it and what do you think about the fact
that at that press conference um boris
johnson said even the most cynical would
agree that this 1.5 is still alive
he did but then look at the headline i'd
give cops six out of ten which actually
if you've been massively involved in it
isn't uh it's not a great thumbs up that
is it i mean it's not very positive at
all so i mean there are mixed messages
coming out of this
but as sebastian's just said what is
absolutely crucial is holding them to it
and we've been here before haven't we
where things have been promised and
they've not materialized and we're kind
of at a point now where really things
have got to materialize so even if we've
got a weakened
watered-down version the crucial thing
is that the countries that have agreed
things stick to them so it'd be really
interesting to see how things are
enforced how countries behave once the
spotlight because suddenly the spotlight
does fade off these issues when there
isn't a massive conference and the
international
interest dim so i think we've just got
to
demand the actions now we've had the
words right because we're still uh well
alex trump is still the president for
another year isn't he until cop 27 uh in
sram shaykh in egypt let's leave cop now
and have a look at the front page of the
metro
uh sebastian just hours before the
service at the senate half the queen had
to pull out
she must be extremely disappointed this
is an extremely important service for
her isn't it
it is and that obviously the queen seems
to have gone through a period of subtly
and below normal health shall we say
that she's pulled out of several public
events she did not go up to cop
and she has cancelled several trips and
basically just stayed to recuperate and
her majesty was spotted with a walking
stick for the first time and we and it
was said by buckingham palace she very
much wanted to do the um the remembrance
day sunday she's only missed a handful
of times in her very long range either
been abroad or being in hospital being
pregnant or that sort of thing so this
is obviously a very stark moment and i
think you can understand why people are
worried but at that um press conference
earlier boyce johnson said that he'd
seen her majesty for one of their weekly
audiences between the monarch and the
prime minister and that she was in very
good fighting fit spirit but uh the
papers are saying that she's got a back
strain or back sprain i should say at
the moment then i think everyone will be
hoping she does get well and is back to
her normal self very soon but you could
also see today that the royal family was
very um well represented from prince
charles by prince william and the
duchess of cambridge as well and i think
when you look at that you can obviously
see that that in the next you know 10
years or so is how the royal family is
going to be represented at this events
and as always i think they got a ton of
it pretty much right
nancy what do you think and it is it is
so unfortunate isn't it that this back
sprain has nothing to do with her
hospitalization last month
absolutely and people are worried it's
obvious people are going to be worried
but if this was
any member of anybody else's family if
this was your or my grandma great granny
we would have insisted that she did the
right thing for her own health so
hopefully this is what she's doing she's
looking after herself so that she can
keep going for as long as possible
because she is very dear in the hearts
of the nations and we all know how much
this event means to her and how
difficult it would have been to make
that decision to not go but
at her age as we would say to anybody
she's got to put her health first and
fortunately the family stepped up as
they tend to do in these occasions and
so hopefully she's at home recuperating
and quite relieved that it went so well
okay um back in a moment uh grab a cup
of tea because coming up
anti-terror police have arrested three
men after a man was killed and another
was injured in liverpool we're going to
be discussing that after the break
[Music]
hello again you're watching the press
preview with me now nancy fielder and
sebastian payne hello again to both of
you let's let's discuss what happened in
liverpool a horrific attack um nancy do
you want us to just take us through
what we know
absolutely so i mean the details are
emerging about this all the time and
what we're hearing is that three people
have been arrested one person died a
taxi driver had a very very lucky well
looking very near miss and managed
somehow to get out of the taxi there's a
massive explosion it was just outside
the women's hospital in liverpool so
there's an awful lot of eyewitness
accounts of people who've just given
birth who are trying to breastfeed or
something is a massive explosion but
also it was around 11 o'clock just as
they remember silences were starting and
it was very close to where people in
liverpool were paying their respects um
there's a lot more detail to emerge but
it's just absolutely heartbreaking for
everybody in liverpool and everybody
concerned it was it's on the front of
the times um the police are indeed
calling it an incident um sebastian but
the counter terror police also involved
in this
yes and the front page of tomorrow's
daily telegraph says that uh three
suspects were arrested under the
terrorism act and there were um
addresses raided across the city there
and some of the eyewitness accounts are
really quite start this one on the front
of the telegraph that says there was a
large explosion which blew out all the
windows and sent the windscreen flying
to the air white smoke came billy out of
the car was extraordinary the driver
managed to escape let alone survive and
the driver of this who has been named in
several papers is david perry and
managed to escape serious um um injuries
there which if you look at the pictures
are really just quite extraordinary
there's also a lot we don't know about
what happened in the pool at the moment
but obviously our thoughts with
everybody who was involved with this
those people in the hospital
and just i think you have to look at the
bravery of that taxi driver who looks as
if you know he's done something very
noble at this point
yeah because there are reports and they
are just reports and claims in the
telegraph and in the mail nancy that
he jumped out of the car and locked
um the man who died inside the car
absolutely that's what the reports are
saying that the passenger got in
the taxi they drove their destination
nothing much was said there was no
conversation but then the taxi driver
noticed him sort of doing something
suspicious in the back um and he managed
to somehow leap out of the taxi and lock
the passenger in um and thus saved his
own life as well as who knows how many
of people's um
so yeah it is all unraveling fairly
quickly and but there is a lot to still
be confirmed by police
yes i'm sure a lot more will emerge and
as i said the police are just saying
it's an incident now but counter-terror
police are involved and they and these
the men were arrested under the
terrorism act
let's move on to booster jabs now
because this is really interesting isn't
it um sebastian it comes on the day that
austria imposes a lockdown on
unvaccinated people the front of the
time saying cover booster shots for
under 50s now
i feel like this has been quite
inevitable ever since the booster
program began because obviously everyone
in those top most vulnerable categories
have been getting their boosters and
they're one of the reasons that covert
case appear to have been declining um
over the past couple of weeks and
obviously everyone's still saying
including the prime minister that it's
going to be a difficult winter ahead but
those boosters are providing some much
needed unity particularly for the most
vulnerable and i feel like as soon as
that happened we know how prevalent the
delta variant is and how quickly it
transmits it felt like it was only going
to be a matter of time i assume the
reason they hadn't done this until now
was a supply issue they were focusing on
the most vulnerable but it feels like
there's some countries are now saying
that to be fully vast is to have three
shots and i think given this
announcement um or reports of it within
the times then that's enough to where
we're going to be that due to the waning
immunity getting those three jobs will
be quite quite crucial and then
obviously next year we have to start all
over again with the booster things but
given the fact we seem to have escaped
um not implementing plan b that was more
covered restrictions in england
including work from home and face mass
was a lot of speculation and chatter
within whitehall that was going to come
in last month well it seems as if the
case is dropping it's going to be okay
but the government's still clearly very
nervous hence why they're looking at
boosters for everyone